oh
[Musique]
ça viendra bien d'auckland
insight
en plein coeur de la médina de marrakech
un riad de grand luxe
il est 10 heures du matin soit de
l'intendante n'a pas une minute à perdre
aujourd'hui elle doit accueillir 12
personnes et à 1000 euros la nuit tout
doit être impeccable
trois familles de la région parisienne
ont loué ce riad ensemble pour y passer
une semaine de vacances le charme du
luxe orientale associé à un design
moderne c'est l'originalité de ce riad
et c'est ce qui en fait son succès vous
voulez voir la salle de massage et à la
musique les projets tous pour leur peau
monsieur madame 7 et si votre suite
le riad compte cinq chambres dont 2
suites comme celle ci toutes sont dotés
d'un lit king size d'une salle de bain
de luxe
l'agneau mais surtout d'une télévision à
écran plat et de la connexion internet s
est s est là les touristes veulent du
dépaysement certes mais sans renoncer à
la technologie moderne
c'est ce qui m'a attiré en fait le côté
zen côté moderne le choix des couleurs
c'est vrai que c'est surprenant
d'arriver dans dans un riad aussi
tendance si joli festival ont très joli
tout est surprenant c'est la découverte
dès l'ouverture de la porte sur la
terrasse panoramique
c'est marrakech que l'on découvre avec
vue imprenable sur les montagnes de
l'atlas
mais ce qui justifie le prix de ce riad
c'est le service
il est digne d'un hôtel 5 étoiles
gagner 2
cuisinière à demeure qui concocte des
plats régionaux mais aussi une masseuse
un serveur un jardinier une femme de
ménage et un chauffeur une kyrielle
d'employés aux petits soins 24 heures
sur 24 des vacances de rêve qui leur
coûterait trois fois plus cher en france
c'est pourquoi marrakech est devenue
l'une des destinations préférées des
français
[Musique]
à moins de trois heures d'avion de
toutes les capitales européennes
le maroc accueille 8 millions de
touristes par an l'industrie touristique
est devenu la principale source de
revenus du pays
mais le roi mohamed6 ne veut pas
s'arrêter là
il compte faire du maroc le premier pays
touristique d'afrique
depuis deux ans voilà à quoi ressemble
le pays
un vaste chantier
des villes entières sortent de terre les
ouvriers travaillent 7 jours sur 7
[Musique]
les le maroc est il capable d'absorber
un tel flux de touristes sans bétonner
ses côtes sans bousculer ses traditions
et surtout sans perdre son sens de
l'hospitalité légendaire
impossible de visiter marrakech sans
faire un tour au souk un univers coloré
à l'atmosphère étrange
[Musique]
quarante mille artisans y vendent à peu
près de tout en s'y baladant les
touristes ont la sensation de sentir le
pays de comprendre comment vivent les
marocains cet après midi nos trois
françaises quittent le ryad pour une
séance de shopping
[Musique]
à saint-aignan du super prime pour les
beaux yeux contient des beaux yeux nos
beaux yeux ça doit bien lui même tous le
font aussi du super voit combien c'est
celui-là je laissais pour à 45 euros
mais le sujet suscite comme à côté
regardez regardez
non non non ça alors parekh à côté au
final elles obtiennent le prix souhaité
120 dirhams
mais oui la lune aux yeux derrière cette
image de carte postale
la réalité est bien différente
l'authentic n'est plus qu'une façade
[Musique]
car la médina n'appartient plus aux
marocains derrière les portes qui
jalonnent les ruelles
la majorité des ryads traditionnelle a
été acquise par des étrangers
certains ont carrément acheté des
quartiers entiers des pâtés de maison
transformée en palais personnel de
plusieurs milliers de mètres carrés
comme celui de cet homme d'affaires
italien qui a souhaité garder l'anonymat
ici beaucoup
12 on va baisser sa garde
des milliers de mètres carrés vendu une
bouchée de pain
c'est ce qui a attiré des acheteurs du
monde entier
du coup le prix des maisons a flambé un
riad acheter cent mille euros il ya dix
ans peut se revendre entièrement rénové
jusqu'à un million d'euros aujourd'hui
des sommes astronomiques qui ont fini
par chasser les marocains du coeur de
marrakech
[Musique]
il est 19h et souad l'intendante du riad
5 étoiles quitte son travail
j'ai passé ma journée de repos loyer
maintenant je vais commencer ma journée
de maman il n'y a pas une minute à
perdre
comme tous les soirs soit pour retrouver
ces deux enfants rester seule chez elle
loin de la médina chaque jour elle passe
une heure dans le bus son seul moment de
tranquillité
selon xu oui c'est le seul moment que
j'ai pour moi
à 34 ans soit n'est pas tout à fait une
femme marocaine comme les autres elle
est divorcée
c'est légal mais très mal considérés
dans ce pays aux moeurs traditionnelle
elle vit loin de sa famille et élève
seule ses deux enfants
l habitat l coude il ya un quartier
populaire situé à une dizaine de
kilomètres du centre ville toute la
journée jeux dans le riyad
il ya le bassin choi et les jacuzzis
tout est beau le décor est magnifique et
là j'entre chez moi c'est la réalité
le quartier populaire mais c'est bien
vers 18h ebuya les enfants c'est mon
livre à moi
la rue est jalonnée de petites épiceries
moins cher qu'en centre ville
ici pas d'éclairage dans les ruelles pas
de lumière non plus dans l'entrée de
l'immeuble où habite suad j'ai le loyer
modique 75 euros par mois sans l'eau
courante
c'est le maximum qu'elle puisse s'offrir
avec ses 200 euros de salaire elle
partage ce minuscule deux pièces avec
dia et 12 ans et haitham 11 ans ils
dorment tous dans la même chambre qui
sert aussi de salle à manger et de salon
[Musique]
le barrage moto gp pour celles baettig
une télévision couleur et un frigidaire
les deux seuls luxe auquel s'est permise
pendant que ces garçons sont pris par le
match soit continue à s'activer élevé
seule ses enfants n'est pas une mince
affaire surtout dans un pays musulman
comme le maroc la femme dit forcé c'est
mal vu je parle à personne j'ai les
moindres eu le plus petit nombre de 2,2
d'amis je fais pas la fête pour ne pas
avoir de d'agression je m'habille
correctement pour ne pas avoir d'
agression je parle doucement je ne
rigole pas si fort dans la rue je fais
attention mais des fois je
j'entends ce qui est 10 mais ça me fait
rien
l'important pour moi c'est faire vivre
mes enfants tout ce qu'ils peuvent dire
tout ce qui peut faire je pense aux
enfants ils pourront de moins quand vous
êtes une famille oui quels qu'ils nous
disent les garçons j'ai pas une grande
maison avec tout dedans tu ne verras
plus à travailler
c'était beaucoup
c'est ce que tu fais pendant un match
impeccable et l'adaptabilité tu veux pas
faire des expériences
il est 22 heures et comme chaque soir
soit se concentre sur les devoirs de ses
enfants elle n'a toujours pas manger et
demain elle se lèvera comme chaque jour
à 6 heures pour aller travailler au riad
si à marrakech les traditions semble
lourde à porter et pourtant elles
réussissent à se faire oublier quand il
s'agit de séduire les touristes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
il y a bien sûr les traditionnels
danseuse du ventre
[Musique]
mais ce qui attire les fêtards du monde
entier ce sont ces immenses boîte de
nuit capable de rivaliser avec ibiza ou
bien me musique techno
alcool et femmes dévoilées ici on oublie
vite qu'on est dans un pays musulman
[Musique]
vincent benvenuti est agent immobilier
installé depuis dix ans à marrakech
il a vécu de près la transformation de
la ville et la flambée des prix
[Musique]
si hier il vendait surtout des ryads et
des maisons traditionnelles
aujourd'hui il oriente ses clients vers
des appartements neufs ou des terrains
nus loin du centre-ville
car désormais les meilleures affaires se
font à la campagne
ce club comme ici à 12 km de marrakech
vincent l'agent immobilier a vendu ce
terrain à un retraité français il y a
deux ans un ancien entrepreneur du
bâtiment a acheté un hectare de terrain
nu pour cent mille euros
il y a fait construire cette luxueuse
demeure
[Musique]
un vrai palace à 900000 euros mon ami
daniel est ce que tu m'as bien tu as vu
pour une fois j'ai fait l'effort promis
à temps avec audrey bientôt vend sa
maison
daniel est fier de nous la faire visiter
la maison 960 m² habitables
on continue et plaisir moi j'aime bien
que ces escaliers même assez monumentale
volumineux tasse et escaliers qu'elle me
servait une belle réussite
ici c'est le salon marocain tout ce que
vous voyez ici ce soir les fauteuils
l'étape de salon j'ai tout fait faire la
salle de réconfort en bonne
entrepreneurs daniel n'a pas lésiné sur
le marbre
savané coup de le faire il y a aussi un
sauna il a été construit sur mesure et
un mam la salle de bains elle aussi a
été construite sur mesure
difficile il faut prévoir assez
longtemps avant ce qu'on prend la main
parce que il ya deux mille clubs doivent
être parmi les cinq chambres que compte
sa maison daniela sa préférée ça c'est
la chambre vraiment marocaine
quelle est la libération moi tout ça oui
les couleurs les oublie tout ça c'est
moi qui tous choisis chaque participant
j'ai un peu artiste c'est la pièce apéro
c'est un poème préféré ça là c'est quand
même super après il ya la piscine ici
avec le bassin jets d'eau et vous
envisagez de passer combien de fois par
an ici
183 jours 183 jours par an c'est le
minimum de temps qu'il faut passer à
l'étranger pour échapper au fisc
français en résidant au maroc
daniel pète dix fois moins d'impôts
qu'en france ils économisent ainsi près
de 200000 euros par an
de quoi s'offrir du personnel de maison
car le maroc propose une main-d'oeuvre
particulièrement bon marché une grande
maison comme ça il faut quand même déjà
il faut deux personnes au jardin mon cas
qui s'occupe des piscines du nettoyage
extérieur de femme de ménage qui font la
cuisine ça fait cinq personnes vues des
salaires marocain qui en fait sont pas
chargés mois en france j'aurais même pu
j'aurais une femme de ménage amis
qu'avec les charges sociales quoi c'est
à peu près ça on va à peu près mais pour
construire des maisons de luxe comme
celle ci il faut des terrains toujours
plus de terrain
c'est pourquoi le roi cep de nombreuses
terres aux promoteurs étrangers
pour attirer une clientèle haut de gamme
une quinzaine de complexe de luxe sont
en cours de construction financés par
les plus grands noms du tourisme
international
ils abriteront des hôtels cinq étoiles
des spas et surtout des golfs grandiose
[Musique]
à ce jour la ville en compte déjà 4 mai
une dizaine d'autres golfs sont prévus
ce qui ferait de marrakech la ville la
plus équipée d'afrique une offre
démesurée en plein désert des milliers
de mètres cubes d'eau gaspillée pour
entretenir les golfs juste pour le
plaisir des joueurs qui aiment changer
de parcours tous les jours autant de
terre en moins pour les marocains qui
sont obligés de s'expatrier de plus en
plus loin de marrakech
donc là voici là la fen de la ville tels
que c'était il ya encore un an d'envoyer
on voit très bien la délimitation du
périmètre urbain à une centaine de
mètres juste en face de l'ancienne
limite de marrakech des logements
sociaux se construisent à toute allure
ça veut dire qu'en fait les gens sont
retroussés de plus en plus loin
exactement comme toutes les grandes
villes les centres villes deviennent un
bureau un grand standing en commerce est
beaucoup plus élevé et il faut aller sur
les périphéries nord comme souvent
d'ailleurs dans les villes c'est soit le
nord qui sont les quartiers les plus
populaires
une telle pénurie de logements que le
gouvernement enchaîne les programmes
sociaux sur des kilomètres jusqu'à la
ville nouvelle de tamansourt tu
[Musique]
situé à 20 kilomètres de marrakech cette
cité tentaculaire va accueillir les
nouveaux banlieusards lé les
constructions à perte de vue sur 1200
hectares à terme
taman sources devrait loger trois cent
mille personnes une population
équivalente à celle de la ville de
nantes
[Musique]
pour l'instant les moutons et les vaches
sont encore un coin de verdure mais plus
pour longtemps
ces grands ensembles rappelle les cités
ghettos créé dans les années 60 en
france
même façade lisse même fenêtre minuscule
même allé sans fin et malgré le soleil
et la peinture rose l'impression de
circuler dans une ville dortoir domine
[Musique]
il ya déjà plus de 5000 logements qui
ont pris preneur qui ont été acquis et
donc vraiment l'actuellement on est en
phase de livraison où tout va se livrer
c'est pour ça que vous voyez un peu une
ville fantôme où il n'y a pas de
commerce encore où il ya très très peu
d'habitations a très peu de jambes donc
tout se met en place un peu surprenante
parce qu'on a vraiment l'impression
d'une ville qui sort de rien qui sort du
néant
[Musique]
fatima vient d'acheter un appartement de
46 mètres carrés ataman soucht dans
l'une de ces nouvelles tours pour 20000
euros
elle habite ici avec son mari et ses
deux grands enfants
c'est notre chambre et celle des enfants
comparé aux ryad où elle vivait dans la
médina son appartement paraît minuscule
mais pour fatima
il marque un changement culturel profond
dans sa vie il y encore peu de temps
comme beaucoup de marocains elle vivait
en famille ils étaient 15 à partager la
même maison toutes générations
confondues
il n'y a pas mieux glisser avant nous
étions mélangé avec mes frères mes
soeurs et leurs propres enfants
je suis indépendante avec ma famille
quand on est seule avec ses enfants
on vit en paix pour elle la liberté et
le confort moderne n'ont pas de prix
fatima et son mari se sont endettés sur
20 ans pour vivre ataman soucht
[Musique]
à 500 kilomètres plus au nord la ville
de fès cette ancienne cité impériale
refusent de subir le sort de marrakech
elle n'est pas prête à sacrifier son
authenticité pour le tourisme de masse
un fez le temps semble s'être arrêté et
moeurs traditionnels ils sont encore
particulièrement vivace et
l'architecturé moyenâgeuse domine
[Musique]
mais surtout la capitale culturelle du
maroc abrite la plus grande médina du
monde classée au patrimoine de l'unesco
des centaines de rue elle forme un
labyrinthe où il fait bon se perdre un
bazar sympathique avec pour seul repère
les 350 mosquée de la médina
fès l'authentic séduit de plus en plus
les touristes ils sont près de 3
millions à visiter chaque année les
célèbres tannerie
[Musique]
dans les fosses multicolores au cachet
médiéval les hommes transforme les pots
en cuir
ces techniques ancestrales se
transmettent de génération en génération
un spectacle envoûtant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un patrimoine exceptionnel que les
habitants de la médina de fès ont décidé
de sauvegarder
contrairement à marrakech leur maison
ancestrale ne sont pas à vendre
c'est grâce au combat de cette jeune
femme
avec l'aide de la région elle a réussi à
regrouper 30 familles autour d'un projet
transformer leur riad en maison d'hôtes
plutôt que de les vendre à un étranger
originaire de fès
leila skalli 32 ans est architecte et
depuis deux ans elle forme les familles
marocaines à l'accueil des touristes
étrangers
elle leur a appris les règles de vie à
l'occidentale alimentation confort
d'hygiène
ce matin c'est l'aboutissement de leur
formation
elle va leur distribuer à tous le même
linge de maison sont les serviettes et
qu'on a préparé avec le logo et à l'as
face
pourquoi alors à nolay et cochet
walt logo diana en arabe syharath
signifie visite chaque maison aura un
jeu complet de linge des serviettes de
bain des serviettes de toilette et des
draps un équipement indispensable pour
les touristes car traditionnellement
dans les ryads on se contente d'une
couverture pour dormir 5092 dirhams soit
460 euros
chaque famille doit payer son lot tout
ça évidemment sans intérêt et ce ne sont
pas des seuls avantages dont bénéficient
ces familles modestes
leïla a convaincu les autorités locales
de les aider financièrement en payant
les rénovation des salles de bain par
exemple
avec son équipe elle compte développer
ainsi à fès un tourisme plus responsable
plus touristiques puissent bénéficier
également aux marocains et on me regarde
qui résident manière à ce que la ville
continue à leur appartenir 90% des
personnes de ces de ces familles
vendée leur maison au lieu de la bande
et la garde et il y reste
grâce à l'association naïma a pu sauver
son riad accompagnée de son mari et de
sa fille aujourd'hui elle accueille un
couple de corréziens
pour ces quatre jours de farniente à fès
ils ont choisi de vivre chez l'habitant
à 25 euros la nuit c'est une façon
économe de vivre à la marocaine qui sont
ces jeunes chez vous à la différence de
marrakech
ici les ryads sont rénovés dans la plus
pure tradition marocaine pas
d'équipements high-tech et encore moins
de meubles design c'est très joli c'est
très joli et puis c'est beaucoup plus
convivial que qu'un hôtel quand on s'est
regardés marrakech maintenant toutes les
rien toutes les maisons et sont vendus
faille et aux étrangers
alors nous attachons veux pas commettre
la même erreur alors on a fait ça pour
garder la maison
c'est dommage je vous les voulez jeter
[Rires]
[Musique]
tout le monde y trouve son compte
la famille conserve sa maison et les
touristes voyagent utile on appelle cela
le tourisme solidaire
ici une culture différente des géants
différents pour des coutumes différentes
qui peuvent nous apprendre des choses et
on sait ces choses là qu'il faut qu'on
ramène à la maison
sans ce pas madame cigale sinon non
merci ça fait tendance hier ah oui oui
non si bien
[Musique]
de plus en plus de vacanciers fut les
villes et partent à la recherche de
grands espaces
il y a bien sûr les classiques balades à
dos de chameau ou au coeur du désert
mais certains touristes veulent voyager
autrement faire en sorte que leur
passage profite à la région et non pas
aux grands voyagistes
[Musique]
à six heures de route de marrakech l'anr
guy est une vallée profonde et reculée
au coeur de l'atlas la famille julien
est venue de toulon dans le sud de la
france pour y passer une semaine de
vacances
laurence et jean luc ont emmené leur
fille dans l' aventure margot 12 ans et
emilie quatre ans leur guide
la scène est un gars du pays son
objectif développer le tourisme dans la
vallée l'une des plus pauvres de la
région pour la vallée c'est le seul issu
de développement et d'amélioration des
niveaux de vie des gens et c'est parti
pour cinq heures de marche sous un
soleil de plomb
heureusement les mules porte les bagages
et même la petite dernière
[Musique]
à
sa g sec mais les paysages sont
grandioses
eh bien
[Musique]
au détour des chemins se nichent des
villages citadelle c'est ici que vivent
les tribus berbères d'anciens nomades
[Musique]
et maintenant
et ces paysages à de neige verdure de
fleurs
petit village en pisé la semaine de
dépaysement leur revient à 1760 euros
tout compris
une somme qui suffisent à faire vivre
cinq ou six familles de la vallée
[Musique]
papa m'emmenait la maison si wayne va
l'amener à l'aller bonheur des enfants
mais ils sont bien là c'est vraiment un
point aujourd'hui la famille julien va
vivre un moment privilégié une cérémonie
un peu particulière dans la vallée l'eau
est un bien précieux une source alimente
généralement plusieurs villages alors
pour éviter les litiges entre paysans
berbère il faut élire un responsable
chargé de répartir lot de la façon la
plus équitable possible
aujourd'hui c'est le jour où la tribu
istres se retrouvent ici au niveau de la
source
parce que c'est à partir de cette source
qu'ils eric tous les champs et elle
était par celle de la de la vallée donc
ils se retrouvent ici pour choisir le
monsieur comme elsa py laisser le long
de l'eau est aujourd'hui l'élection se
promet d'être houleuse après deux ans de
bons et loyaux services le chef de
l'orphelin nouveau mandat laissez moi
tranquille je ne veux pas continuer je
n'en peux plus de cette gestion de l'eau
je fais un effort fait une confiance on
va t'aider on va te donner un coup de
main non je ne veux plus j'ai essayé
d'être juste
j'ai essayé d'être correct avec tout le
monde j'ai été impartial et ça ne m'a
causé que du tort
je suis devenue l'ennemie des gens
pourquoi pour bien un folklore qui amuse
les touristes pendant ce temps là
laurence a rejoint les femmes et les
enfants de la tribu rester à l'écart
comme le veut la tradition berbère
elle tente de communiquer à sa manière
10 en 10 11
emilie emilie l'a4 en quatre ans
4-4 lab on voit qu'on est dans une
cérémonie où ils transmettent des choses
et on peut se poser nous des questions
que ce qu'on transmet aux enfants
est ce qu'un enfant à 10 12 ans pu
imaginer qu'on peut vivre encore sans
électricité sans internet est un donc là
je crois c'est importante peut-être
d'apprécier ce qu'on a aussi d'avoir une
juste valeur des choix
[Musique]
après deux heures d'âpres discussions le
chef de l'eau a fini par céder à la
pression de la foule
il reçoit le brin d'herbe symbolique qui
en fait le nouveau responsable de l'eau
de la vallée pour un an
l'adie
[Musique]
m
la famille julien a encore quatre jours
de vacances pour découvrir d'autres
merveilles dans la vallée et vivre au
rythme du peuple berbère loin du béton
[Musique]
oh
un tourisme rural qui reste marginal
pour attirer un plus grand nombre de
visiteurs
le maroc compte sur la richesse de son
littoral
pour
des milliers de kilomètres de plage
déserte que le roi a décidé d'exploiter
mohamed 6 affiche un objectif ambitieux
attirer 10 millions de touristes d'ici
2010 il a donc lancé un plan d'envergure
faire sortir de terre
six stations balnéaires la première à
voir le jour
saïdia se situe au nord-est du maroc
dans une région longtemps délaissé
proche de la frontière algérienne des
terres que l'état marocain a cédé à un
promoteur espagnol pour une bouchée de
pain
voilà à quoi ressemble leur projet le
film promotionnel est édifiant des bars
de plage tous les 300 mètres des
résidences des villas et des
appartements au bord de piscine géante
un centre commercial de luxe une
clinique privée
trois golfs et surtout une marina
[Musique]
en tout une véritable ville prête à
accueillir trente mille touristes
officiellement ce projet titanesque doit
être prêt pour cet été des maisons qui
émerge du sable des squelettes
d'immeubles saïdia est encore en travaux
à quelques semaines de l'inauguration
elle a des allures de ville fantôme
[Musique]
il y a deux ans nous avions rencontré
les responsables du projet à cette
époque là l'optimisme était de rigueur
pour l'architecte marocain et le
directeur du site
juan cano saïdia devait rapporter gros
[Musique]
pour les vrd goff la marine à tout ça
ces sessions millions d'euros vous
investissez 600 millions d'euros et vous
espérez gagner combien normalement avec
25 % on a déjà content
mais deux ans plus tard les choses ont
bien changé à la suite de la crise
immobilière le promoteur espagnol a fait
faillite
le chantier de saïdia appartient
désormais à un groupe marocain
exit donc juan cano place à hassan zerma
le nouveau directeur du groupe en poste
depuis six mois
l'homme a changé mais pas le discours le
groupe fadesa maroc se porte bien nos
projets ne sont pas l'arrêt nous
continuons d'investir sur ce site comme
sur d'autres à marrakech tétouan etc etc
voilà en fait on voit l'avenir de façon
optimiste nous serons chabal est prêt à
ouvrir la station donc le début juin
inchallah si dieu le veut
le site sera prêt pour l'ouverture
officielle dans un moins
mais autant le dire il reste du pain sur
la planche à ce jour deux quartiers sur
dix sont terminés la majorité des villas
des immeubles et des jardins reste en
chantier
en réalité seul un golf sur trois est
fin prêt
[Musique]
et sur les neuf hôtels prévus en bordure
de plage deux seulement s'apprête à
ouvrir le plus majestueux le barcelo
fait la fierté de saïdia un cinq étoiles
architecture d'inspiration andalouse
avec ses 1200 chambres
c'est le plus grand hôtel d'afrique pour
que le palace soit prêt à temps
tout le monde est sur le pont des
dizaines d'ouvriers s'activent pour
poncé le bois aménager les jardins
astiquer chaque mètre carré de la
piscine
[Musique]
à l'heure qu'il est difficile d'imaginer
à quoi ressemblera cette suite son
mobilier est encore sous plastique et
pour le privilège d'avoir la vue sur la
mer
il faudra débourser 800 euros pour une
semaine mais selon nos informations cet
été l'hôtel est loin d'être complet
la marine a aussi aurait dû être
terminée mais il ya eu un petit problème
faute d'études préalables
la digue a bien été construite mais à
l'envers résultat le port de plaisance
est ensablée les bateaux ne peuvent plus
naviguer
[Musique]
alors depuis un an c'est le branle bas
de combat sur le port le chantier tourne
jour et nuit
il faut reconstruire une nouvelle digue
en un temps record
[Musique]
car la marina c'est le produit d'appel
de saïdia la ville est loin d'être
achevé mais la promesse d'une place pour
leurs bateaux et du soleil toute l'année
ont convaincu un couple de retraités
français d'acheter un duplex dans cet
immeuble
donc ça c'est l'entrée c'est très donc
là c'est le coin repas et ça c'est le
coin salon qui donne sur la terrasse
pour manger
l'enfer on y mange déjà l'appartement
compte trois terrasses comme celle ci
donc là vous êtes face à la mer face à
la mer certes mais encore faut-il avoir
une bonne vue dites que vous avez quand
même
non j'ai pas le nez sur la mer mais
y'avait pas d'appartement habitez en
bord en front de mer
et en prime un petit immeuble de deux
étages va être construit juste en face
de chez elle des désagréments compensé
par le prix ce 220 mètres carrés en
duplex leur a coûté 180 mille euros
c'est trois fois moins cher qu'en france
alors ça c'est la vue sur le milieu du
complexe et sur la piscine sans eau pour
l'instant le résidence se trouve dans
l'un des quartiers les plus achevés de
saïdia tous les lots ont trouvé preneur
mais en ce mois d'avril les volets
restent désespérément clos
vous n'êtes pas beaucoup de voisins à
c'est très calme c'est très calme mais
comme on est jetés des gens relativement
solitaire c'est pour nous ça ne nous
gêne pas beaucoup le seul petit on peut
dire que c'est un problème c'est d'aller
chercher le courrier à la boîte postale
parce qu'on n'y a pas encore de tourner
deux on est tellement peu qui a pas aux
contracteurs qui viennent
hormis ça y'a moyen ça me va très bien
paul fait partie des rares chanceux dont
le logement a été livré dans les temps
car saïdia comme le reste du monde subit
la crise financière un promoteur anglais
avaient pour mission de construire une
partie de la ville mais il n'a plus les
moyens de terminer les travaux sur un
chantier
seuls deux sont en cours d'achèvement
[Musique]
toutes ces maisons de rêve vanté par les
catalogues reste un rêve
[Musique]
mais officiellement pas d'inquiétude
la station va bien ouvrir dans un mois
pour nous le prouver le directeur
commercial zouhir used by tient à nous
emmener visiter l'un des fleurons de la
station le centre commercial baptisé la
médina dans moins d'un mois
elle doit être inaugurée par le roi
mohamed 6 en personne
il revient de boutiques une centaine des
boutiques de prêt-à-porter des
restaurants des boutiques d'artisanat et
un peu de tout excepté quelques marques
qui vont être là vous voyez là parce
qu'ils emploient six ans n'a marionnaud
on ne rasera aussi sais pas peut-être
lacoste aussi on ne réussit lacoste
peut-être passée donc il y aura beaucoup
de boutiques de standing le directeur a
l'air un peu gêné car la réalité s'avère
différente si les marques provost et
lacoste maintiennent l'ouverture d'une
boutique pour cet été zara et marionnaud
elles se sont retirés du projet selon
nos informations il n'y aurait plus que
20 magasins sur les sont prévus à
l'origine
mais les problèmes existent déjà
à l'autre bout de la médina la porte qui
donne sur la plage est fissurée de
partout un détail que zouhir yousfi
aurait préféré qu'on ne remarque pas
voilà ce qu'on peut m'expliquer ce que
ces kits
six mois
il ya plein de fissures partout alors on
vient d'être créée c'est bizarre ça
vient d'être créée mais comme c'est un
grand immeuble donc désolé mais je peux
vous l'expliquer mais à ma façon
comme ils disent tout le monde ici parce
qu'un grand mère comme celui là par
exemple
donc faut prendre place sur la terre une
fois qu'il a construit pour prendre
place sur terre donc il y aura des
fissures normal donc là on est en train
de le traiter et cette partie il a fait
partie de la deuxième tranche qui va
ouvrir en été 2010 des immeubles qui
s'enfonce dans le sable
mais ce n'est pas tout en front de mer
certains hôtels semble déjà vétuste
avant même d'avoir reçu leurs premiers
clients ils perdent leurs tuiles et une
partie de leurs crédits
plus insolite encore des cartes y en a
qui sont sous l'eau car cet hiver il a
plu au maroc
comme il n'a pas plu depuis 50 ans les
canalisations de saïdia n'était pas
conçue pour cette météo exceptionnelle
elle déborde donc sur des kilomètres à
la ronde
[Musique]
le paysage sec et aride s'est transformé
en rizières et les habitations alentour
ont été inondés durant trois mois
les autorités locales ont creusé en
catastrophe cette tranchée pour évacuer
l'eau vers la mer
[Musique]
pour mohamed benata militants
écologistes de la région
ce n'est qu'une aberration de plus dans
ce projet de station balnéaire c'est pas
leur masse quelqu'un qui doit faire des
gérer des projets de gérer le
développement
il doit réfléchir doit consulter les
scientifiques ensuite et les techniciens
ya des buts des bureaux d'études sérieux
pour faire ça malheureusement je pense
que c'est les décisions hâtives qui ont
causé tout ce ce gr brouillage la crise
est passé sur leur sur la botte de cydia
malheureusement mais le pire pour
mohamed
c'est que la station de saïdia dénaturer
la plage la plage qui a bercé toute son
enfance c'était comme ça dans le temps
sur 14 kilomètres il y avait une très
belle plage on appelait ça la perle
bleue malheureusement tout a été
sacrifié pour le tourisme de masse pour
construire ce projet touristique
d'envergure
les promoteurs ont rasé les dunes et
leur végétation et en particulier cette
plante qui avait pourtant une fonction
très précises cette plante et les
merveilleuses c'est la mafia arena la
première ligne sur la côte et vous
pouvez le constater même malgré le vent
qui a aujourd'hui le sable est en
équilibre qui ne bouge pratiquement pas
parce que il est retenu par cette mairie
aux plantes
effectivement la différence entre
l'ancienne plage de saïdia et la
nouvelle est saisissante
je pense à ça c'est bon ça cette réponse
j'élimine si tu peux prendre ça il ya le
sens du vent et il ya le sable la timide
il n'est plus retenu par la plantation
nationale qui étaient là si tu sembles
qui est perdu pour la place et on va le
trouver ce sable à sion la cour lycée
après il va partir plus loin encore on
arrive par il pas très loin de sa poule
et les habitants maintenant qu'ils
souffrent du sable ça fait plus de trois
années qu'ils ont des des tempêtes de
sable chaque fois ils doivent nettoyer
leur logement mais les écologistes ont
beau multiplier les plaintes auprès des
constructeurs leur portée reste faible
auprès des dirigeants de saïdia les
écologistes ils disent que c'est une
catastrophe parce que avant il y avait
des plantes qui permettait au simple de
rester sur la plage et que l'on le vent
sacré du sable partout dans la ville ce
que vous répondez à ça on est obligées
d'en ménager la mer pour accueillir les
touristes et les résidents des villas
des appartements qu'on a vendu on est en
fête pour les habitants qui disent que
dans le bourg de saïdia maintenant il ya
du sable qui rentre dans la vie la voix
y en avait pas pas de réponse à la
question écologique
zouhir yousfi préfère rappeler les
bienfaits du projet pour la région
une fois qu'il va terminer ce site il
recrée 48 mille postes de travail car
bon c'est oui mais postes directs et 40
mille postes indirects est un plus pour
ça et pour la région
le directeur commercial masquer du mieux
qu'il peut son malaise
mais il n'est pas au bout de ses peines
car à saïdia les défauts les plus graves
sont bien cachés alors que la ville
s'apprête à accueillir trente mille
personnes
nous avons voulu savoir comment seront
traités les eaux usées
oui normalement une station d'épuration
qui était faite par l'office national de
l'eau potable
[Musique]
maintenant moi j'ai pas le droit de vous
oui je veux juste voir qu'elle est
important de savoir comment ces pros de
fonctionnent les exos les coûts pour
débuter et où sa voix si j'achète une
maison je vous posais la question est
bien sûr moi aussi paris est donc vous
répondez quoi aux gens qui vous pose la
question
dit pas je sais pas non sinon vous
sentez pas bien sûr
vous répondez quoi
très méchante
[Rires]
non non c'est prévu dans cette partie
non ils sont en train de faire entre la
et de notre côté
d'après zouhir yousfi la station
d'épuration ce construite ici
bizarrement à peine arrivé il passe un
coup de fil à son patron oui merci
il va pas trop pourquoi je peux que nos
anges 3 fins déclaration officielle sur
ça certes des tuyaux de canalisation
sont bien entreposées ici mais nous
allons découvrir que ce n'est pas
l'emplacement de la future station
d'épuration ou se cache-t-elle alors les
écologistes de la région aimerait bien
le savoir
un paysan dans l'exploitation se trouve
sur les hauteurs de saïdia alerte et
mohamed l'écologiste
il y a deux mois alors qu'il venait
cultiver son champ
abdou berkane a fait une drôle de
découverte il ya l'entreprise qui est
venu sont demandés consultations
commencent à creuser pour amener aux
conduites de refoulement des eaux usées
sans aucune consultation ni autorisation
n'est compromis avec les propriétaires
si une tranchée a été creusée à travers
le champ de blé de ce paysan ce n'est
pas un hasard car à 100 mètres de là de
grands travaux sont en cours
c'est ici à dix kilomètres de la ville
touristique à l'abri des regards que se
trouvera la future station d'épuration
en réalité les eaux usées de saïdia
seront simplement retenu dans ce grand
trou un filtrage et un recyclage
sommaires dans les nuisances sur
l'environnement inquiète les riverains
en attendant que cette station soit
opérationnel une solution provisoire a
été trouvée pour traiter les déchets des
3000 premiers touristes de saïdia c'est
dans ce container que les eaux usées
sont stockés avant d'être rejetée dans
la mer un environnement dénaturer une
station balnéaire qui accumule les
retards et les malfaçons saïdia devait
être le fer de lance de cette région
délaissée
mais aujourd'hui les habitants sont pour
le moins circonspect n'est pas content
pour qui le fait gagner de l'argent mais
son père de nos biens les générations à
venir
ce qu'on va leur laisser si demain ma
fille va le donner demander pourquoi
êtes vous avez fait ça qu'on va répondre
à l'inquiétude des familles grandit
chaque jour un peu plus elles craignent
que le tourisme de masse ne détruise à
terme toute la plage ces questions
d'argent ce qui questionne d'économie
c'est le baiser de st c'est le site
touristique
ça marche à evo mètres l'un de l'autre
on espère que ça marche pas
il est trop tôt pour le dire mais une
chose est sûre l'objectif fixé par le
roi d'attirer toujours plus de touristes
et repousser de plusieurs années sur les
six stations balnéaires prévu de ne
verront sans doute jamais le jour et
quatre autres accusent un retard
alarmant en ce début juin les familles
marocaines profitent des beaux jours et
des derniers moments de tranquillité sur
leur plage quand saïdia tournera à plein
régime
il leur sera difficile de trouver une
place au soleil des bons partis de la
place
si on continue comme ça on va entrer à
la base avec des tickets
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]